hi this is dr. Gregory Sadler I'm a
professor of philosophy and the
president and founder of an educational
consulting company called reason IO
where we put philosophy into practice
I've studied and taught philosophy for
over 20 years and I find that many
people run into difficulties reading
classic philosophical texts sometimes
it's the way things are said or how the
text is structured but the concepts
themselves are not always that
complicated and that's where I come in
to help students and lifelong learners
I've been producing longer lecture
videos and posting them to youtube many
viewers say they find them useful what
you're currently watching is part of a
new series of shorter videos each of
them focused on one core concept from an
important philosophical text I hope you
find it useful as well we're worrying
about whether it's right or wrong
whether it applies to all cases or just
some cases what does it actually say
what did you get from from MacIntyre I
sort of gave a few kind of evidence if
you were on the spot and you had to
explain it to somebody else who wasn't
in this class what would you say why did
you start because if it's a moral theory
that
based on the person's a moment okay
that's it that's good stir in what way
what expresses your when you're making
moral judgments or using moral language
terms of good bad right wrong
should-should that's our stuff what are
you really doing you are really just
expressing because he puts it feelings
attitudes I have extended to include
desires any expression of your own
self-interest let me read it one of one
or two things that people who actually
were alone at this MacIntyre that wob
but sometimes it's nice to hear
works so this is AJ here he was a famous
philosopher who's associated with let's
go logical positivism but I don't know
that much to be says here's my the
saying that a certain type of action was
right or wrong I'm not making any
factual statement not even a statement
about my own state of mind I'm not
saying that this is how I think about it
what I am doing is expressing certain
moral sentiments
yeah of the man the man is ostensibly
contradicting me who's taking a
different position is merely expressing
his Moral Sentiments there's be says
there's plainly no sense in asking which
of us is in the right neither of us is a
Cernik asserting and genuine proposition
neither of us is actually saying
something meaningful we're just
expressing how we so if I look at you
know somebody doing an action I say that
person is bad or that person is
disgusting or that's a horrible thing to
do then you say I think they want to do
I think it's a great thing that they're
doing it Aaron would say well neither
one of us is right neither one of us is
wrong we're just expressing how we how
we feel about how many says in every
case in which one would commonly be said
to making an ethical judgment the
function of the relevant ethical word so
not all the stuff but just the ethical
terms is purely a motive that's used to
express feeling about certain objects
but not to make any assertion about he
says it's worth mentioning also that
ethical terms don't serve only to
express feelings they also have another
to browse right and they're buying to
motivate them too so if I see you doing
something what's a typical thing that
the professors get on the students about
so Oh perfect yeah okay so you're on
your cell phone and I say you know you
really shouldn't do that and what am i
doing I'm Express we might disapprove
and I'm trying to get you to feel that
you really want not to do that I'm
trying to get you to feel they had in
some way try to have you reflect on your
own thing I'm trying to get you to feel
in such a way that if the person next to
you also gets out their cell phone you
don't like that right you don't see them
as has now akin to you you're more like
me and you say that's a bad thing
meaning I don't like that and then we'll
get you to act differently right then I
can do the monitor way off right I mean
that would be one way to do it
that might produce more emotion quickly
and yeah or I might be very sweet you
know we're not supposed to have cell
phones in this classroom we have
kind of implicit contract here yeah it
might be something like that but if air
is right all we're doing it it's the
same thing where we're really just
trying to express a certain disapproval
and get you to feel that disapproval to
yourself and get you to change your
behavior what's something that students
want professors to do that they
typically don't do that they should not
like give everybody a is or something
like that something that professors fall
down on the job
we've got the stuff that you guys work
with twit feedback delivered you know
say within a week right there's a week a
good amount of time I mean they even
that's kind of pushing it for some facts
okay so you say to me then something
like you really want to get your gear
we're handing in the workout time
themselves you really ought to get the
work done on your part on time you know
you should be held to the same standards
as us what you're doing there is you're
expressing a kind of positive energy and
in order you know if you say dr. Sandler
is a good professor so far because he
actually you know graded our stuff
within the first week I don't see how
that goes the rest of the semester right
you're you're expressing approval of me
or my actions and then I can feel it
warm and fuzzy inside because what if
they had this when you guys were kids
cold and pricklies and warm and fuzzies
like a
as a kid you know probably they did
change all this but that's what the
emotivist theory is is saying our moral
language basically is we're expressing
how many how do you feel what are the
attitudes are whether we approve or
disapprove of things and when we
disagree about it there's nothing to be
done other than try to maybe bring
pressure to bear on somebody you can't
actually rationally argue them into it
because we could they'd already hold
that position it's interesting to ask
that I'm certain and it certainly yes no
nobody would be right nobody would be we
all just have our own views now like
some of the morning mr. pointed out that
doesn't prevent us from feeling that
other people are one of the guys who
don't like putting a link to in the like
you know supplemental stuff from you but
not suggesting after briefing this class
he was pointing out that you know we're
emotivist that doesn't mean that we have
to say Hitler is a-ok we can feel that
what he's doing is definitely wrong
and I'll watch footage of the
concentration camp and say this is
horrible but all we're actually doing is
expressing our feelings we're not
actually we're not actually right in the
sense that it informs any sort of
objective work and of course you know
Hitler apparently didn't think that what
he was doing was wrong because the right
to good but all they were doing their
part was expressing their feelings
pretty and they're doing a lot more than
expressive actions are significant so in
the instance yeah there's nobody's right
nobody's wrong you got the sense that
the other person now that's not the
whole story though because motive mists
like McAteer points out if you really
buy into this theory then you probably
think that people should quit all this
moralizing then if you say that you're
actually saying that other people
as you don't
like Sara style I'm law yes sir so
there's two answers but it's it's an
important question it's not guy Stephens
he's a pretty particularly important
moment of this thing he wrote at the end
of one of his essays ethical statements
are social instruments they are used in
a cooperative enterprise in which we are
mutually adjusting ourselves to Pintrest
advice so there are ways in which we try
to make people feel the way that we want
them to feel and do the things that we
want them to do and everybody else is
doing the same thing to us so when your
mom disapproved of something that you
were doing or didn't like one of your
friends and set they're a bad person if
you're doing the wrong thing all she was
doing is expressing her feelings but she
was trying to get you to feel likewise
when you responded in kind I suppose
inside know they're a great person you
were just expressing your feelings of
Trinity here long to see things your way
how they change your view it's not quite
so so innocent they they think that
we're constantly is there any kind of
pressure on each other the change we see
that in our society that's that you know
if we're emotivist s-- yeah I want you
to stop doing the action that you're
doing and I really hate it it's a really
strong I don't know we could say that
just
suggests that you should go to different
layers I'm really
again the emotivist thinks there's only
right and wrong from the perspective of
how I see it there is no this is one of
the problems with the theory so you're
kind of leading us ahead to some of the
criticisms so motive ISM is like
McIntyre says it's the doctrine all
evaluative judgments and specifically
moral judgments are nothing more than
expressions preference attitude or
feeling insofar as they're expressive of
those things character so what are the
implications so I put some of this in
either for you moral things aren't true
and false they're indexed to the
individual person even more importantly
if a motive isn't actually is right then
there's no rational way to decide
disciplines so when it comes to big
issues the moral things that we say get
involved in politics or activism we just
feel different ways of that we may
produce news and we may make arguments
but that's just sort of window dressing
it's not really what's going on those
are words being used kinda stools now
one of the things that I want to point
out with this McIntyre says that if
somebody's saying from an emotive this
perspective X is good what they're
saying is something like I like X you
should like it too or her a Docs or I
approve of X where I have a positive
feeling or attitude towards X and you
can ask why a person has this positive
feeling right now here's the thing so
you can come up with a story about why
people have that particular feelings
they do right if you're in a boat of
this it doesn't make sense to he ask
should they feel good if you're in a
motivates you sort of take that out of
the toolbox or there why is that well
anytime you're bringing in these moral
terms you've got the same problem again
don't you if you say that well let's
take some sort of thing that they
probably can all agree shouldn't have
good feelings like yeah okay I mean
heroin addicts would probably disagree
but you know I think we think we can
have a consensus that that you shouldn't
shoot up here right no matter if I
that's even thought of it don't shoot up
heroin don't smoke crack don't don't use
it in any form there's other ways they
can be used of course those are the big
three you know at least in our country
right now
no because of others not going to
consider Coca's or is cracking here but
we can wait we can also do PCP
okay so we say you shouldn't you
shouldn't do these sorts now form in
emotivist perspective all we're doing is
expressing our disapproval right and the
other person who says but I love crack
it's really nothing you know or somebody
else who's like you know the contrary
and says why don't people should be able
to do whatever they want even if it's
crack right they're just expressing
their feelings as well and if you
motivates are right there's no rational
way to decide between this and you can't
even say about the person who say legs
crack you can't say well that's that's a
mistaken point of view that you've got
there
you shouldn't feel that there's
something wrong with you because again
what are you doing you're just
expressing your feelings you're not
actually expressing anything that has
made real